au speed Park l'ambiance était à l'unité
pour fêter la rentrée étudiante
l'agglomération de 5 an en éoline
organisé une rencontre entre les
différents établissements supérieurs le
9 novembre dernier au programme kting
Laser Game bowling billard ou encore
karaoké une occasion unique pour les
étudiants d'échanger et d'apprendre à
mieux se connaître on a organisé cet
événement parce que il est important
pour nous de faire rencontrer les
étudiants 50 ans neline notamment il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de première année 2è
année postbac qui sont présents
aujourd'hui et le but c'est de le faire
découvrir tous les services qui sont
dédiés aux étudiants qui appartiennent
donc à l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
une première pour Saint-Quentin en
niveline qui semble avoir réussi son
Paris moi ça me fait plaisir d'être là
parce que j'ai pas l'habitude de sortir
forcément et je trouve que que ce soit
entroué par la ville c'est plutôt sympa
voui ça fait rencontrer du monde ouais
c'était vraiment super ça nous permet de
découvrir justement speed Park c'est
c'est une première pour moi je ça c'est
bien parce que bah déjà on peut passer
une après-midi assez sympa entre ài
surtout là en période de partielle ça
nous fait un après-midi assez sympa et
puis on avait jamais entendu enin moi
j'avais jamais entendu parler de par
avant donc ça m permis de découvrir
endroit donc au total près de 300
étudiants de 12 établissements
supérieurs différents étaient
présents